>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
HELLO, AMERICA.
BY NOW YOU'VE HEARD AOC AMONG
OTHERS WERE ARRESTED LAST NIGHT.
SHE TRULY IS AN AMERICAN HERO.
IT WAS BRUTAL.
TAKEN OUT IN CUFFS.
TECHNICALLY HER SHIRT HAD CUFFS.
MAYBE FRENCH CUFFS.
SHE DID SURRENDER WITHOUT
FIGHTING.
IF HER PANTS HAD CUFFS SHE WOULD
HAVE PRETENDED TO BE A LEG
IRONS.
REAL HANDCUFFS, NOT SO MUCH.
THAT DIDN'T STOP HER FROM
PRETENDING.
I HATE IT WHEN PEOPLE DO THIS TO
ME.
WHEN I ASKED PEOPLE TO PUT ON
HANDCUFFS AND THEY SAY "I'LL
JUST PRETEND I HAVE THEM ON."
I WOULD BE LIKE SHORT, AND I
WILL PRETEND TO PAY YOU AFTER.
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK DANA JUST WENT INTO AN
ARRHYTHMIA.
YES, I PAY PEOPLE TO WEAR
HANDCUFFS.
SHE DID THIS BECAUSE SHE KNEW
THE MEDIA WOULD OBEY.
LET'S WATCH THE TAPE.
>> ABORTION RIGHTS ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
WHAT DO WE DO?
>> Greg: SHE WOULD BE A GREAT
MIME.
LIKE THE LATINA VERSION OF
MARCEL MARCEAU.
HERE SHE IS LATER IN HER JAIL
CELL.
OF COURSE AOC WAS MOCKED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA FOR IMITATING BEING
HANDCUFFED WHICH IS A CHANGE FOR
HER USUAL CHANGE FROM BEING
MOCKED BY IMITATING A
CONGRESSWOMAN.
THAT'S NOT EVEN BEING AS CLOSE
TO AS DISGUSTING AS I CAN BE.
SHE WAS GINGERLY ESCORTED ALERT
TO A HOLDING AREA.
SHE RAISED HER FISTS TO
SUPPORTERS.
THEN SHE CROSSED HER WRISTS
ENOUGH OH HANDCUFFED POSITION.
AS TALL A TALE AS AOC NEARLY
BEING KILLED JANUARY 6.
A PERSON NEVER MET A GENERATION
SHE COULD MAKE ABOUT HER.
SHE REALLY IS THE AMBER HEARD OF
D.C. POLITICS.
I AM SURPRISED SHE DIDN'T CLAIM
SHE WAS NEARLY KILLED ON 9/11 OR
DURING THE TET OFFENSIVE OR THE
BATTLE OF BUNKER HILL.
OR THAT SHE DODGED A BULLET WHEN
LINCOLN ASKED HER TO SHUT UP AT
FORD'S THEATER.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I GET IT.
NOTHING MAKES YOU COOLER THAN
GETTING ARRESTED FOR TAKING A
STAND.
YOU KNOW, I SHOULD DO THAT.
>> HI THERE.
DOES YOUR WEEK REPETITION NEED A
BOOST FROM A CRIMINAL SITUATION?
INTRODUCING FAKE ARREST
REPUTATION TRANSFORMATION.
WE WILL OVERHAUL YOUR IMAGE BY
ARRESTING YOU FOR COOL CRIMES IN
FRONT OF YOUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
UNLIKE MY EX-WIFE'S DIET PILLS,
WE ACTUALLY GET RESULTS.
THIS INTO OUR SATISFIED
CUSTOMERS.
>> AS YOU SEE OUR QUARTERLY
NUMBERS OF 2% EXCEED OUR
FORECAST OF 1.944%.
>> HOLD IT RIGHT THERE.
YOU'RE UNDER ARREST FOR LEGAL
DRAG RACING.
RUNNING AN UNDERGROUND FIGHT
CLUB AND EXCEEDING THE MAXIMUM
DONATION TO THE SALVATION ARMY.
LET'S GO.
>> SCREW YOU, PIG.
>> SUCH BADASS.
>> I WANT HIM TO GET ME
PREGNANT.
>> ME TOO.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THAT IS
A REAL NUMBER.
I DO NOT BLAME AOC AT ALL.
SHE KNOWS THAT SHE CAN PLAY THE
MEDIA BECAUSE HE SO DESPERATELY
NEED HER TO PLAY THE PUBLIC.
IT'S LIKE BOB SO YOU'RE SAYING
THE CLASSIC SONG NIGHT MOVES.
I USED HER.
SHE USED ME BUT NEITHER ONE
CARED.
WE WERE GETTING OUR SHARE.
IT'S LIKE THAT PICTURE OF THE
BORDER AGENT THAT WENT CRAZY
VIRAL.
THE AGENT WEBB'S MIGRANTS.
THE MEDIA SCREAMED IN UNISON
LIKE THE TABERNACLE CHOIR
STUBBING THEIR TOES AT THE SAME
TIME.
BIDEN SAID HE WOULD GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT LIKE IT WAS THE
AFTERNOON BOWL OF CREAM OF
WHEAT.
ONE ADULTS INFORM THE PRESS, THE
STORY WENT AWAY.
WITHOUT ONE CORRECTION.
IN A MOVE THAT WOULD MAKE KAFKA
SAY THIS SITUATION IS MY
NAMESQUE.
THANK YOU.
JIM SAID IT WAS A GOOD JOKE.
THEY PUNISHED THE AGENTS EVEN
AFTER THEY WERE FOUND INNOCENT.
TRUMP WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
DICTATOR.
THE STORY ISN'T ABOUT THEM OR
THE SQUAD.
IT'S ABOUT THE MEDIA OF COURSE
WHO CHOOSE TO ADMIT FACTS TO
CREATE AND PRESERVE THEIR
NARRATIVE.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS KABUKI
NEWS WHERE PARTICIPANTS PLAY ACT
AND THE MEDIA PRETENDS IT'S REAL
AND THEN AMPLIFIES IT TO THE
PUBLIC.
IT IS CONSTANT AND IT ONLY FLOWS
IN ONE DIRECTION FOR TODAY
THANKFULLY WITH HELP, SAVVY
CONSUMER CAN SEE RIGHT THROUGH
IT.
WHO CAN YOU THANK FOR THAT?
♪ ♪
I EXPECTED MORE APPLAUSE BUT
OKAY.
MOST AMERICANS NOW KNOW THAT
WHAT THE MEDIA PRESENTS ISN'T
REAL BUT ARTIFICIAL
REPRESENTATIONS OF THE HIDDEN
STORY.
IT IS LIKE THE TRASH CAN ON YOUR
LAPTOP SCREEN.
IT'S NOT REALLY A TRASH CAN.
YOU AREN'T REALLY DRAGGING THAT
INCRIMINATING PHOTO AND THROWING
IT AWAY EVEN WHEN IT MAKES IT
REALLY CUTE SOUND.
BUT IT WANTS YOU TO THINK IT IS.
IT'S ALL JUST SYMBOLS NUMBERS
ENDING ACTIONS GOING ON BEHIND
THE USER INTERFACE THAT WE NEVER
ACTUALLY EVER SEE.
WHAT YOU DO SEE HOWEVER IS WHAT
THEY ALLOW YOU TO SEE.
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER STUFF
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
WHO KNOWS HOW MANY CRYPTIC
TEXTS, EMAILS AND BODILY FLUIDS
ARE EXCHANGED BETWEEN
JOURNALISTS FOR SUCH FAVORABLE
COVERAGE.
THAT IS THE NEWS.
HOW THE NEWS PRESENTS THE NEWS.
EXAMPLE OF THIS PHOTO.
BORDER PATROL AGENT ON
HORSEBACK.
A BLACK MIGRANT, A WHIP.
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED, THE MEDIA
THINKS, SO THEY BLEW IT UP BUT
THEY HAVE THOSE IMAGES IS THE
TRUTH THEY WILL TELL YOU BECAUSE
IT'S TOO MUCH WORK AND IT
BETRAYS THEIR AIMS.
WHAT WAS THE STORY BEHIND THE
STORY?
THE BORDER PATROL AGENT IS DOING
HIS JOB THAT THE GOVERNMENT WANT
TO, PROTECT THE BORDER.
THE WHIP IS A RAIN USED TO
CONTROL THE HORSE.
THE BLACK MIGRANT IS AN ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND AGENTS ARE LOOKING
OUT FOR HIS HEALTH TOO.
THAT IS THE STORY BEHIND THE
IMAGES.
THE SAME THING WITH THE SQUAD'S
PROTEST.
IT'S CLEAR SO WHY BOTHER TELL
YOU THE TRUTH.
TV PICTURE IS WORTH 1,000 WORDS.
IT'S A THOUSAND TIMES MORE
POWERFUL WHEN NONE EXPLAINED IN
ITS PROPER CONTEXT.
WHETHER IT'S
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR CNN THEY
USE IMAGES FALSELY DERIVATIVE
THE REALITY THAT OFTEN ISN'T THE
REALITY AT ALL.
THE SAME THING WITH MORE.
LEGIT SUFFERING AND RUBBLE.
I'M SORRY, I'M CONFUSING WITH
WHAT I SEE IN KAT'S OFFICE.
YOU BETTER NOT QUESTION WHAT'S
GOING ON BEHIND THE IMAGE.
HOW DID WE GET HERE.
CAN IT BE STOPPED?
NO, SHUT UP AND ENJOY THE
SLIDESHOW HE PUT TOGETHER FOR
YOU.
PEOPLE ARE CATCHING ON.
THE CONFIDENCE IN THE MEDIA IS
ALMOST DOWN TO ZERO.
WE CALL IT THE JESSE WATTERS
EFFECT.
[LAUGHS]
HE CAN'T HEAR YOU.
THAT'S THE GOOD THING BECAUSE IT
WILL HOPEFULLY LEAD TO NEW
THINGS.
FOX NEWS CAME ABOUT FROM A
DISSATISFACTION OVER THE
MONOLITHIC LEFTIST MEDIA.